hello everyone and welcome back to our
broadcast of these 2023 US championships
we have a very very special guest in the
studio Dr pastell welcome aboard well
thank you so much not at all and uh for
Kate and I this is a great honor you're
the president of St Louis University
please introduce yourself uh to our
audience yeah it's great to be here I'm
Fred pastello president of St Louis
University uh very proud of our Unity
University and our chess team uh we have
one of our students on the chess team in
fact competing in the tournament here
absolutely well I mean andalia she the
first four games she had wins in a
couple and she let them slip away it's
really oh very very tough but the St
Louis University I was seeing in uh the
uh uh papers that give to me you're the
34th president of the St Louis
University you have a very big history
the St Louis University history Year yes
thank you so um we've been here since
1818 we're the oldest university west of
the Mississippi River uh with St Louis
University High the longest continuing
organizations in St Louis and we're
located in Midtown which is burgeoning
right now and very close to the uh
Central West End and where Lou chess
club and the Hall of Fame and we're very
pleased with that proximity and to be
supporters of it we love the Rex and
Genie sinkfield they've done so much for
this region so much for the Central West
End St Louis that club that Hall of Fame
and St Louis University so absolutely
I'm delighted to be here with you too
and love how you call the game well
thank you for uh you of course you and
your wife are hosting the strategy
across the board that's our big
fundraiser that happens each and every
year in December tell our audience about
that and how people can be involved in
the strategy across the board please so
uh on December 2nd the 7th annual
strategy across the board at the Chase
Park Plaza everybody knows and loves the
chase It's a Wonderful celebratory event
grows every year supports This
Magnificent cause to further chess
education and all the culture and arts
that are around it I don't know if
everyone realizes here in St Louis not
only is there the club and we push out
the education of Chess and people come
and play but it's really an art artistic
venue a cultural venue with the concerts
and the things that are sponsored by the
uh Hall of Fame and uh the chess club it
is impressive and the transformation
that's taking place that's actually some
of it centered right on that club so uh
my spouse Francis and I are delighted to
be a part of this we hope you'll be able
to join us December 2nd at the Chase
Park Plaza for the 7th annual Gaya and I
know you both are uh musical lovers
you're you're the musical series and
there it's held at the World Chess of
Hall of Fame and at the St Louis chess
club we've got some
uh a rooll I want to say photographs of
uh the World Chess Hall of Fame as well
as the St Louis chess club sorry we
don't Fred I I messed up it's the sleo
pictures because we talk about their CH
I know we are big supporter I want to
show you where verian trains his team at
the slooh University where are we here
so uh this is the St Louis University
campus we are on International Jesuit
university we in addition to the
campuses here in St Louis we have a
campus uh in Madrid a full degree
graning campus and we're very proud of
our team which started in uh 2016 very
much supported by Rex and Genie
sinkfield and we're delighted uh to have
their support and to be affiliated with
the uh chess club here in St Louis and
thank you for showing those pictures
pictures of our beautiful campus here
mid St Louis so thank you very much and
I'm curious do you play yourself chess
because I know you're a big supporter of
Chess of Chess Hall of Fame uh what
about you and the game I I play
occasionally and I play uh Mr sinkfield
occasionally and Mr sinkfield uh has one
more than I have and delights uh in that
I think enjoys reminding it yeah I got
news for you you got a really good
trainer it's Lou his name is Grandmaster
vuan acopian take a cou lessons with him
that is a wonderful idea a great next
time you'll be ambushing Rex with I
would Delight in that yes it's wonderful
Fred thank you so much for joining us
thank you for having me it's really a
great pleasure it's been a pleasure
thank thank you for supporting chess and
having just incredible team at
absolutely I look forward to watching
more of the games absolutely and indeed
we do have games uh as uh we go to our
standings here in round five Kate take
it away yes so let's take a look at